today on the matt wall show a ship named
after the peters harvey milk was
christened by a transgender navy veteran
over the weekend it was a very
encouraging and inspirational spectacle
to china also eight people died during a
rap concert is the performer to blame
for that and the sports media is beside
itself with outrage because aaron
rodgers didn't get the covet vaccine
plus snl looks for comedy and abortion
and only succeeds in proving the
opposite point from what i think they
were trying to prove and our daily
cancellation today will be once and for
all canceling equality it's time and we
have to do it we'll do all that and much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know food prices are going up uh gas
prices are going up prices for
everything are going up and that's why
you know any opportunity you get to save
money you've got to take advantage of
that's just a good that's a good
strategy for life in general especially
now with inflation
uh and i'll give you one one thing i'll
make it really easy for you it's called
get upside it's a new app and you can
save money on gas every single time you
fill up the tank my listeners are making
up to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up just download
the free get upside app in the app store
on google play or on google play right
now you can use promo code wall should
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back
don't pay full price at the pump ever
again
why should you get cash back using get
upside just download the app for free
use promo code walsh to get up to 50
cents a gallon cashback on your first
tank 25 cents a gallon after that some
people who drive a lot are making as
much as 2 300 a month in cash back and
there's no catch the cash back gets
added right to your account and it's
really as simple and easy as that
so what are you waiting for just
download the free get upside app and use
promo code walsh to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cashback on your first tank
that's code walsh
gay rights icon harvey milk was a child
molester and a pederst known for
shacking up with troubled teenage boys
one of his long-term boyfriends and
please note the air quotes around that
term was 16 years old mentally ill and
suicidal milk was in his mid-30s at the
time of this relationship again the air
quotes
the gay rights hero preyed upon boys of
this kind he brainwashed them in fact he
had a real affinity for brainwashing as
he was friends with and a defender of
cult leader jim jones once writing a
letter to jimmy carter describing jones
as a quote man of the highest character
milk had cult followers from the
people's temple working on his campaign
and most of them would go uh just a few
months later to commit mass suicide at a
compound in south america
so that was harvey milk for you but in
spite of all this in spite of harvey
milk being essentially the kevin spacey
of his time but creepier
were meant to celebrate and honor him
because he advanced the gay rights cause
he was a martyr for the cause we're told
even though he was murdered and he was
murdered but he was murdered
when he was a city supervisor
by a disgruntled employee for reasons
that had nothing to do with homophobia
and the same guy also killed the mayor
who was straight and you never hear
about the mayor
poor guy
nonetheless harvey milk was gay and he
was killed and that's enough to make him
into the jesus christ of the gay rights
movement a man who died for the
homophobic sins of all mankind
since then the mythology of harvey milk
again the middle-aged man who sexually
preyed upon high school boys
has grown and expanded and been
literally cemented into the public
consciousness in the form of statues and
memorials and all kinds of things a few
years ago the post office proudly
unveiled its new commemorative harmony
milk harvey milk stamps
and yesterday a navy ship the usns
harvey milk was christened in the san
diego harbor and there to do the honors
was trans navy veteran paulinera let's
listen to that
paula would you please christen the ship
the name of the united states of america
i christen the harvey milk
may god bless the ship and all who sail
in here
okay wonderful and paulo there
sounds and looks just like a woman right
now the good news is that the usns
harvey milk will one day soon become a
very inclusive and progressive coral
reef at the bottom of the pacific when
it's destroyed by china in our coming
war indeed on the same day that a
biological male named paula was
christening a ship named after a child
molester the hill published an article
revealing that our government is
unnerved quote unquote by china's
growing military capabilities from the
article it says america's defense
establishment has watched threats from
beijing rapidly grow in multiple areas
including recent hypersonic missile
tests and expanding nuclear arsenal
strides in space and cyber and seemingly
daily threats to taiwan
we're witnessing one of the largest
shifts in global geostrategic power the
world has witnessed joint chiefs of
staff chairman general mark milley said
wednesday when speaking about china's
recent military advances quote they are
clearly challenging us regionally and
their aspiration is to challenge the
united states globally a potential shift
in the global balance of power is
worrisome to u.s officials and lawmakers
yes worrisome
so worrisome that the defense department
is preparing us for this inevitable
confrontation with a world superpower
by recruiting and promoting women
emphasizing tolerance and diversity
and focusing on the threat posed by the
you know 25 white nationalists in the
country 23 of whom are federal agents by
the way
worrisome indeed
but aside from the implosion of our
military which is right now collapsing
under the weight of its own wokeness
it says something about our broader
society
that harvey milk
is the kind of man we honor
you know a person in san diego a
spectator in san diego over the weekend
might have witnessed the coronation of
the harvey milk love boat and then walk
downtown to pay respects at the george
floyd memorial
all in a day you know nice nice day out
on the town
these are the sorts of people we pay
tribute to now
a cult-loving petrist and a violent
felon and it's not just that both men
were deeply flawed and guilty of
horrific evils though they were
is that neither achieved anything
tremendously significant in their lives
and both are remembered today mainly
because their deaths proved useful to
the left
they are victims and we are a culture
which celebrates victimhood
now it would be it would be bad enough
if we were just
tearing down the columbus statues and
military memorials
just taking the founders names off of
schools and so on if this was a general
reaction against quote unquote
problematic historical figures
problematic because they were men and
not angels
sinners and not gods
and the end result was that we we don't
memorialize or honor or remember anyone
out of an overabundance of shame for our
fallen nature and a belief that no man
can possibly be worthy of such treatment
and death
if that was the case it would be bad
that it would be unhealthy
and i would resist it
but it wouldn't be nearly as bad as what
is actually occurring
see we're not experiencing a simple
erasure of history as much as a
reordering of it
so we're not getting rid of columbus
jefferson and washington we're replacing
them
and all the rest of our traditional
heroes as well when mount rushmore is
finally blown to smithereens and it will
be
new faces will be carved on the
mountainside it won't be left alone
the new faces of george floyd harvey
milk
it's hard to know who else will make the
cut
i mean the litmus test is that you must
be worshipped by either blm or the lgbt
lgbt lobby
and you must have a compelling victim
story
whether the story is true or not and
most of the time it isn't
it doesn't matter if you accomplished
anything accomplishments of anything are
discouraged
virtue is irrelevant also
so what we find is that all cultures
need their mythic heroes
that's a need for a culture
there's a reason why every human society
since the dawn of civilization and
possibly even before that has built
monuments to its ancestors it's an
irresistible human impulse that we all
have
we must have some idea about our past
you know we cannot live in a past less
futureless void
we have to know where we've been we have
to see the footsteps in the sand so that
we know where to go
and what's true of individuals is also
true of societies you become what you
admire
until recently
we followed the footsteps of great men
who achieved great things
and so we continued to produce more
great men who would blaze a path for the
great men to come after them
but we don't care about greatness
anymore
actually we hate it
our heroes now are harvey milk
and george floyd
that's who we admire
or are told to admire
and so
that's who we will become
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well as we get into the uh holiday
season you're maybe you're maybe you're
one of those people that thinks ahead of
time for christmas what gifts are going
to get i'm of course more in the the
realm of waiting until um christmas eve
or something but if you think ahead
which you should here's something to
think about paint your life paint your
life is a perfect gift um
you can get an original painting by a
world-class artist done by hand from any
photo at a very affordable price get a
professional hand-painted portrait
create it again from any photo
all you have to do is very simple you
send a picture any picture to all your
children your family yourself
or you can combine photos into one
painting whatever it is you send it over
and they will put it all together this
is a team of of some of the best artists
in the world and they will work with you
to make sure that every detail is
correct i've done this a couple of times
i've gone through the process i'm always
surprised by how quick the process is
and also how much
opportunity you have for feedback and to
let them know what you like what you
don't like and it's a quick and easy
product
process you get a hand-painted portrait
in about three weeks at
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the painting your money is
refunded guaranteed and right now is a
limited time offer get 20 off your
painting that's right 20 off and free
shipping to get this special offer takes
the word matt to 64 000 that's matt 264
000 text matt 264 000 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
well i hope you had a great uh a good
good weekend at least good maybe not
great let's set the bar a little high
but at least good uh i had a pretty good
weekend i
on not to brag about being a great
husband or anything but um one of my
anniversary gifts
to my wife that i gave her was uh on
saturday you know i said go i i got her
booked her a day at the spa
and i told her to go to go to spot she
did and so i took over with all the kids
and um you know we we
we had a lot of fun we for example
we just kind of went into the
garage to look for random
things to to play with and we found um
some old uh plastic storage bins and my
my kids said can we take the plastic
sports storage bins out back on the on
the grassy hill and try to sled down the
grass in the storage bins and so that
was like two and a half hours of fun
um and the other thing we did
is we played hide and seek and i play
hide and seek with my kids all the time
um
and
and
and
you know up until now the thing i liked
about playing hide and seek with my kids
is that i always win and i would and i'm
it might not surprise you to learn
i'm not one of those dads that lets the
kids win like you're i'm not gonna let
you win you got to beat me
and so i'm probably like 200 up until
today up until this weekend i was 200 no
as a as a as a hide and seek player
against my kids but now they've gotten
older
and they're playing the game on a more
psychological level
so
it was my turn to hide and i was hiding
so i picked a i picked a great hiding
spot i'd already planned it out i was in
this great hiding spot they were never
gonna find me
and then i hear this this loud bang down
in the uh down in the living room
and my son starts screaming out that
he's hurt himself he's like screaming
and crying i heard myself and so i come
running out
to check on him
and he says ha ha just kidding so he he
was pretending to hurt himself to flush
me out of my hiding spot
and i thought you
little this this is i'm here playing
checkers and now you're playing 40 chess
that's
that's that's psychological warfare and
i fell for it
and then they tried it again the next
time i was hiding they went in the
kitchen and started banging around and
saying daddy we're playing with the
knives
that time i did not come out
i was i was wagering that they were just
kidding about playing with the butcher
knives unfortunately they were but even
if they weren't
that was a risk i was willing to take
all right
we'll start with this from the daily
wires as a sold-out houston music
festival attended by an estimated 50 000
people
turned deadly on friday night after a
headliner began to perform
the associated press reported the crowd
gathered for the two-day event in nrg
park at astroworld
uh they suddenly surged toward the stage
during a performance by rapper travis
scott
and he was not just the performer at
this uh astroworld event this it's his
event he puts the event on i believe he
has an album named called astroworld so
this is this is his event that he puts
on
and um it says quote they started
surging towards the stage squeezing fans
so tightly together that they could not
breathe or move their arms and killing
eight people in the chaos
hospitalizing several others according
to the outlet as a timer clicked down to
start the performance
the crowd pushed forward
nick johnson a high school student who
attended the concert told the ap
everyone was passing out around you
everyone was trying to help each other
but you couldn't move you couldn't do
anything you can't even pick your arms
up it just got worse and worse now keep
in mind
eight people
and i mean this is this is a been a
pretty big story in the news i don't
know how it's not a bigger story than
than it's being treated
eight people
mostly kids
died at a concert
but remember
you know uh
prior to to this
what i think was considered the
deadliest and most um catastrophic music
festival ever was woodstock 99.
um
and and in that i i believe that was
like a two or three day festival there
was 100 200 000 people there
and three or four people died and it was
a big deal at the time i can remember it
distinctly
you have three or four deaths with that
many people this is eight people
in a crowd of fifty thousand
in a span of a couple hours died
uh officials caught off the event about
forty minutes after law enforcement
observed concerts concertgoers going
down authorities said a mass casualty
incident had occurred at 9 38 p.m
according to houston chronicle concert
attendee said scott appeared to play his
whole set and finished at 10 15 pm
and travis scott is uh the boyfriend or
whatever i don't think they're married
of kylie jenner one of the
kardashians
um
there there's
there are a lot of weird reports coming
out of this concert and i i don't know
how much of it is true or not
one thing that you heard early on
kind of the rumors circulating online is
that people were being injected with
some unknown substance and this has been
at least partially confirmed there was
there was a security guard who was
briefly
rendered unconscious after feeling a
prick
on his neck
and then he was they they woke him up
and they found markings where he had
been injected by somebody
and there were also reports of
many uh at least several people going
into cardiac arrest
it's not clear if that happened during
this surge or before it or if it had
something to do with what sparked it to
begin with
we had people being injected with drugs
apparently other people being trampled
to death
and
the videos that you see online now and
i'm not going to play them you can go
you can go find these videos there's
many of them circulating
travis scott
is up there
continuing the performance
now early on i read reports saying that
he stopped he stopped multiple times to
try to tell the crowd to back up that
was the report anyway that's the claim i
have not seen any videos
of travis scott stopping the concert
doesn't mean he didn't do it i haven't
seen those videos
the videos i've seen
show travis scott up on the stage while
there are kids collapsing all around and
medics rushing into the crowd and he's
continuing to perform
but now he says that he's very upset
about it and uh and he put out a kind of
a statement on instagram
the next day talking about how
devastated he is and uh
i don't know you
watch this and tell me if you find it to
be sincere
i just want to send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost last night
we're actually working right now
to identify the families so we can help
assist them through this tough time
you know my fans my fans like my fans
really mean the world to me and
i always just really want to leave them
with a positive experience
anytime i can make out
you know anything that's going on you
know you know i'd stop the show and
you know help them get the help they
need you know um
i could just never imagine the severity
of the situation
yeah i find that his reaction
somewhat unsettling i i don't really
eight people just died in front of you
man at your concert
eight kids were just trampled to death
and this is this is his reaction it
sounds like he's
you know it's it sounds like the kind of
statement that you have if uh if you had
to cancel the concert or something
because something happened
and people were you know you had to
issue a bunch of refunds and people were
inconvenienced and so i could see that
yeah really really sorry about that you
know really really really unfortunate
when i watch that especially as he's
right it's not taking his hands off his
head the entire time that's kind of a
tell also that someone's not being
entirely sincere
you know they keep rubbing their face
and everything so he's got all those
tells but it it's and he does it in
black and white he takes the time to
change the filter on it to make it black
and white this is someone who seems to
me trying to seem
devastated and saying that they're
devastated but doesn't really seem that
way to me
one thing you have to
remember about travis scott some
background on this guy
is that he has a history of riling up
the crowd at his concerts
intentionally encouraging them to rush
through security barricades
now i don't know if he did that during
this concert but he has a history of
doing that
i've read some accounts from security
guards who've worked travis scott
concerts
and how he'll kind of turn against them
during the concert and encourage fans to
bum rush them
there's another video very disturbing
from a few years ago where where he was
travis scott was crowd surfing
and some kid in and he looked like he
was 14 or 15 years old maybe younger
some kid grabs his shoe i don't know if
intentionally or not and then travis
scott
loses his mind on this kid and starts
calling for the crowd to you know f him
up and to beat the kid up for taking his
shoe
enlisting a crowd of people who are many
of them already drunk on drugs
they're kind of out of their minds
because that's that's the environment at
these kinds of concerts
it's an environment
intentionally designed to make people
sort of lose their senses
and he's sicking this this mob on this
kid because it took a shoe meanwhile i'm
sure this guy has 500 pairs of shoes at
his house
along with a couple dozen backstage for
all of his outfit changes wardrobe
changes
so that's the kind of guy he is
um
which means i put all that together and
i put this on him i don't know how
i put this on him
at least to the extent that you blame
alec baldwin
for shooting the cinematographer
i mean it wasn't just his fault or other
people involved
but you're the one holding the gun and
you didn't check it and so this falls on
you
travis scott this is your concert
it's up to me you to make sure
everything is safe
at the very least if eight people die it
means that this was a massive
failure
in planning and logistics and making
sure you had enough security there
and that goes to you
you throw an event and eight people die
because
at a minimum because because of poor
planning
yeah this guy should be arrested and
charged already
shouldn't even be a discussion
and then you add into that all the you
see some of the the pictures from the
from the event and you hear some of the
accounts and there's a lot of just weird
satanic imagery everywhere
i was listening to one account from a
girl that was there saying that it was
just and she's not
she said that she's not religious but it
felt weird and satanic even to her even
the kind of music they were playing
and all of this stuff is designed to
make as i said it kind of makes people
lose
their senses lose their mind in a
certain way
and it's designed to have that effect
and then you add in all the drugs and
everything even more so
um
all right let's move on to this
aaron rodgers
the quarterback of the green bay packers
got coveted
and
the assumption immediately once he was
diagnosed with covet is well that means
that he wasn't vaccinated
which that's not a safe assumption
because we know that vaccinated people
get covered all the time in this case it
turns out that yeah he wasn't vaccinated
now he had previously said earlier or
before the season when he was asked
about it he said that he'd been
immunized
but um he didn't specifically say that
he got the vaccine everyone took that to
mean that he got the vaccine
and now it turns out that he didn't he
admitted that he didn't get it
and this has made the media very very
upset at aaron rodgers he is public
enemy number one in sports
and so if you watch football yesterday
or over the weekend
you saw a lot of segments like this
here's terry bradshaw former quarterback
himself in the nfl now a nfl commentator
um here he is addressing aaron rodgers
and and terry bradshaw's like on the
verge of tears because aaron rodgers
didn't get vaccinated let's listen to
this i'd give aaron rodgers some advice
it would have been nice if he'd just
come to the naval academy and learn how
to be honest
learn to learn not to live because
that's what you did aaron you lied to
everyone i understand immunized what you
were doing was taking stuff that would
keep you from getting coveted 19. you
got coveted 19. ivermectim is a cattle
dewormer sorry folks that's what it is
we are a divided nation politically
we're a divided nation on the coveted
night team whether not to take the
vaccine and unfortunately we've got
players that pretty much think only
about themselves and i'm extremely
disappointed in the actions of aaron
rodgers
i'm not mad i'm disappointed you lied to
us aaron you lied to us
uh do you think maybe if he did lie and
i'm not saying i necessarily agree with
that characterization but if he did
maybe it's because you're not owed the
truth terry bradshaw
why should you be told
if i if i lie to you about my medical
history it's because you have no
business knowing that
if someone on the street comes up to me
and says hey have you taken this drug or
got this medicine uh i could say
whatever i want sure i took it
you don't have any moral right to be
angry if you find out that i wasn't
telling the truth later you lied to me
well how it's none of your business
why are you asking the question
why is it terry bradshaw's business
whether aaron rodgers got the vaccine
we're so accustomed to this now to
demanding
that people
reveal their medical history at least as
it concerns covid
that many people have come to see this
as as normal it's not
it's none of your damn business
if aaron rodgers lied to me as a member
of the public about his vaccination
status
i don't care
because i don't care if you got the
vaccine or not to begin with
okay the thing about um
the thing about the truth
is that given the
the circumstance you're not always owed
the truth like there are private pieces
of information about a person's life
and their history and the things they do
with their body
where that's that's not a truth that
you're owed
they don't owe that truth to you
now whether that justifies lying well
that's a whole ethical interesting
debate that we can have but you
certainly are not terry bradshaw has not
owed that piece of information
and meanwhile you can't help but make
the comparison here because
aaron rodgers
is getting
killed by sports media right now you
also have to understand that this is it
it's pretty rare for them to do it it
takes it usually takes a lot
for and it for nfl commentators and for
espn to go after
the most high profile
stars and one of the reasons why they
usually don't do it is because they're
all friends
and so it's awkward and so that's why
they don't criticize each other
but also because these are you know
aaron rodgers
makes terry bradshaw a lot of money
because he's an nfl commentator
and people tune in people don't tune in
to to hear nfl commentators for them
if people are interested in football
then they're gonna be interested in what
the commentators have to say
aaron rodgers is one of the guys that
makes people interested in football
so he's a highly bankable star he makes
a lot of money for all these people they
all know him and are friends with him
and uh and so normally
they let a lot slide
it is pretty unusual
to hear something like what you just
heard
it's so unusual that's um when another
nfl superstar quarterback by the name of
deshaun watson
of the houston texans
when he was accused of rape
by like 20
women or more than 20 women
we have not seen any moments like what
you just saw there with terry bradshaw
they talk it's it is discussed a little
bit
and they're very circumspect about it
and they say well we got to do the
investigation and we'll see this and
that and
there haven't been any moments like that
um
henry ruggs
is a nfl wide receiver
of the las vegas raiders
last weekend he got drunk
and drove his car 156 miles an hour
and slammed into another car and killed
somebody
and there were no moments like that
so the sports media are far far far more
angry at aaron rodgers
for not getting the covet vaccine
than they are at deshaun watson for
raping 20 women allegedly and we've got
to throw the allegedly on that except
that there's again like 20 women have
come out against him
all of them massage therapists and all
of them telling basically the same story
and when that happens i think you could
basically drop the allegedly okay now
you've got it's 20 to one and they're
all telling the same story there's
there's a real pattern here
um so deshawn watson allegedly raping uh
20 women henry ruggs killing somebody
last week
but sports media far far far more angry
at aaron rodgers
for not getting the cover vaccine
and before anyone attempts
some desperate maneuvering here by by
saying well
aaron rodgers could kill
he could he could kill
way more than just one person by not
getting the vaccine
except that
if you're vaccinated as we've said a
million times
if you are vaccinated
and you trust the vaccine
then you shouldn't have to worry about
aaron rodgers infecting you
unless the vaccine doesn't work in which
case
why should aaron rodgers get it
and if you're not vaccinated then that's
a choice you've made that's a risk
you've decided to take and you still
can't get mad at anybody so no matter
what there's there's no grounds to be
mad at aaron rodgers
unless you're trying to be an ethical
purist here and and the reason you're
angry is that he lied to us
yeah he lied to you deshaun watson raped
20 women so i don't know you decide you
decide who we should be
taking a task here more
um staying on the vaccine subject white
house chief of staff ron klain
uh trying to justify the vaccine mandate
made a a very interesting by interesting
i mean stupid analogy let's listen
i'm quite confident that when this
finally gets fully adjudicated not just
a temporary order right uh the the
validity of this requirement will be
upheld it's common sense chuck if osha
can tell people to wear a hot hard hat
on the job to be careful on chemicals it
can put put in place these simple
measures to keep our workers safe
we will find out if the courts agree
a hard hat
okay ron let me explain a few
differences here
first of all um
if you are working a construction site
then most likely you're a
relatively young male
and most likely you're in pretty good
physical shape
which means that covid poses very very
little risk to you
however
a large object falling on your head
even if you are a young physically fit
man
that will still kill you or at least
cause brain damage
so
on a construction site the risk from a
falling object is much much much much
greater than the risk of covet
so that's one of the reasons why you
wear a hard hat also the other thing
about a hard hat is uh you put it on
your body
and then you could take it off
it's not a substance you inject into
your body
now ron klein just looking at him and
his physique doesn't strike me as the
kind of guy who's done a lot of
construction or spent a lot of time
outside
um
so maybe he doesn't really understand
how hard hats work but that's what
they're it's a hat you put on you take
it right back off
um so this is not a requirement that
people
inject a substance into their
body a hard hat serves a certain purpose
and the other thing about hardhat
no side effects you have to worry about
none at all
you don't have to worry about any
long-term side effects any short term
except it gives you hat hair okay so
that's the side effect of a
of a heart hat is that it gives you hat
hair and your your hair looks a little
bit weird when you take it off that's
the side effect as opposed to any any
drug that you put in your body there are
going to be
many more significant side effects than
that potentially for any drug that you
take
to include the cova vaccine
um
but this is they've they've been
grappling around for analogies
really this whole this whole time hard
hat or a lot of times you'll hear the
well it's like wearing a seat belt thing
but there's no analogy that they can
none of the analogies work
because all the analogies they reach for
they're looking at you know temporary
minor measures
where you're doing something you're
taking a safety measure for a specific
purpose
and the amount that it mitigates your
risk is a measurable thing and it's just
it's not analogous
to taking a drug
especially to the government forcing you
to take a drug
one other clip i want to play kind of on
the same
point here do we even have this i think
we do yeah we do rochelle wolenski she's
the cdc director
and um as we you know get into flu
season and everything
now she's suggesting that hey
even if you're not worried about covid
maybe you should still wear the mask for
the sake of protecting yourself against
the flu
[Music]
the evidence is clear
mass can help prevent the spread of
covid19 by reducing your chance of
infection by more than 80 percent
whether it's an infection from the flu
from the coronavirus or even just the
common cold
in combination with other steps like
getting your vaccination hand washing
and keeping physical distance wearing
your mask is an important step you can
take to keep us all healthy
get vaccine fix
we can do this
okay cool so just wear the vaccine or
wear the uh the mask
until we've cured the common cold and
then you'll be good to take it off
why didn't the cdc ever suggest this
before did rachel wallensky in the cdc
did they just discover that the cold
exists
uh or that the flu exists do they
the existence of viruses that can be
transmitted through the air
have they have they just discovered that
or do they just now realize that masks
you know did they not know about medical
masks in the past
if it's a simple
no big deal measure
um
why was it never suggested before covid
but this was a conspiracy theory before
remember
if i suggested or you suggested as many
of us did predicted
that the mass this is going to become a
a a lifestyle
that is that they're going to try to
impose on us from the top permanently
where you have to cover your face
forever
because covid is
all of the
reasons given for wearing a mask because
of covet all of those reasons apply to
the cold and they apply to the flu and
everything else
and if they were making that argument
for that then they're going to say
they're going to say for the flu and
they're going to save it for the for the
cold
only when we made that argument in the
past up until right now that was a
conspiracy theory and now you have the
cdc coming out and saying exactly that
so that's the way it always works all
right next snl um had some hilarious
abortion content
on saturday night
it's from the report from the daily
beast it says saturday saturday night
live's weekend update had a lot of
ground to cover this week especially
given that ice cube a celebrity whom
keenan thompson has perfectly
impersonated before lost out on a 9
million active gig in the sony comedy oh
hell no because he refused to get
vaccinated okay but who cares um
skipping ahead it says the real standout
was and this is an article that's
they're very much impressed with this
bit they're taking a positive view of it
the real standout was guber a clown
played by cecily strong and styled to
look a lot like lunette from the
children's series the big comfy couch
the reason for her appearance to respond
to the stringent texan law that
effectively bans abortion after six
weeks
because just one day before she turned
23 she had a clown abortion
so that's the character she's a clown
who had an abortion and
this is supposed to be funny
let's watch a little bit and find out if
it is
the supreme court heard arguments this
week in women's whole health v texas
about the controversial texas law that
essentially bans all abortions after
just six weeks here to cheer us up well
this can't be right guber the clown who
had an abortion when she was
[Applause]
23. so
goober you had an abortion when you were
23. hey whoa slow down i'm a clown let's
clown around hey smell this flower
you're not gonna squirt me are you oh i
would never
okay oh
gotcha i had an abortion the day before
my 23rd birthday
okay
it seems like you do want to talk about
your abortion well actually i really
don't but people keep bringing it up so
i gotta keep talking about freaking
abortion but it's a rough subject so
we're gonna do fun clown stuff to make
it more palatable
hey who wants a balloon animal
you want a giraffe
you don't have to do
and i wish i didn't have to do this
because the abortion i had at 23 is my
personal clown business but that's all
some people in this country want to
discuss all the time even though cloud
abortion was legalized crosby wade in
1973 here
i mean as always with snl the most
offensive thing about it by far
is that it's supposed to be a comedy
show
and it's just not funny at all i
it's certainly i'd have to acknowledge
there's a real challenge when you're
trying to make a funny joke
about the slaughter of 60 million
children that's not an easy thing to do
i'm not sure that there are any funny
jokes you can make about it
but that definitely wasn't it
um
and in you know we hear from from the
cli the from the goober the clown
this is what we always hear this is the
line we always hear from pro-abortion
especially the feminists well i don't
want to talk about why do you guys keep
talking about abortion
no but but you do want to talk about
it's all feminists ever do is talk about
their abortions like they want they walk
through the street shouting i got an
abortion everyone i got an abortion let
me tell you about my abortion
but then as always if you say well you
know i really don't think you should
have got that abortion that's not a good
thing why are you talking about my
abortion this is my business why are you
so obsessed with it why are you obsessed
with my body
i'm not even i'm not sure even what
point they were
were trying to reach here because i take
two points away from it from this bit
one the most direct thing the most
obvious implication here is that
abortion advocates are clowns
and i agree with that
um but then there's also
you know what you find here is this kind
of classic image
of the uh you know the tears of the
clown right
the clown who puts on this kind of wacky
persona and they put the wig on they put
the nose on and everything but they're
hiding their deep despair that's the
classic image of of the clown
and that is in fact what lots of
post-abortive women do
and especially post-board of women who
are shouting their abortions the
feminists the probe the abortion
advocates
okay you spend any time or you go to a
conference
of you know a feminist conference
planned parenthood or something i
wouldn't recommend it
but you're going to find nothing but the
but goober the clown there a bunch of
goobers running around
all of them talking about how great it
is that they got an abortion how happy
they are about their abortions
isn't it so wonderful
but this is
an act of massive overcompensation
they're trying to hide the the deep
despair and loneliness that they feel
so is that was that the point
is that what they were i don't think
that's what they were reaching for but
that's
it's actually a very good point
in in some ways it's kind of a powerful
bit but in exactly the opposite way that
they intended
abortion advocates are clowns in general
and yes this is what this is what a lot
of these feminists do
they've got the uh you know it's kind of
like the the classic meme that you see
online of the guy holding up the smiley
mask but behind it he's crying that's
that's it right there
that's that is feminism
especially feminism when it comes to
abortion advocacy
because there's really no way just
despite
how they try to fool themselves and and
the rationalizations that they come up
with
you know
there's there's just nobody
who especially as they get older and
they get to the end of their life i can
tell you this
there's not a single feminist
on their deathbed who had an abortion or
one or two or three or five abortions or
whatever
who's going to be lying there on their
deathbed and saying oh man i am so glad
i got that abortion thank god i got that
abortion thank god i'm not leaving any
progeny behind
thank god i'm leaving no legacy thank
god i'm laying here alone
with no one to mourn me
because the only people who would have
mourned me i killed
i can guarantee you there's not one
single feminist saying that
that's all it's always a good litmus
test
it's a good way to decide if you're
making the right choice or not
is to just imagine okay i make this
choice
50 years from now or 60 years from now
hopefully if it's that long and i'm
laying on my deathbed am i going to be
happy
about this choice that i'm making right
now
and if the answer is obviously no
then probably not a good choice to make
you know well there's a a lot of women
who have and it's certainly in the
future
just generations of women who are going
to die alone
with no one to love them
leaving no legacy behind leaving no
imprint on the world at all
it's pretty sad that's that is a very
sad thing um
all right let's finally finish with this
a little bit uh
a little bit more lighthearted this is
from the daily mail
it says this is the report anyway again
i report you decide okay it says he's
supposed to be committed to reducing
emissions but when president joe biden
produced a little natural gas of his own
at the cop26 summit it was audible
enough to make the duchess of cornwall
blush
an informed source has told the mail on
sunday that camilla was taken aback to
hear biden break wind as they made
polite small talk at the global climate
change gathering
last week
the source said quote it was long and
loud and impossible to ignore
camilla hasn't stopped talking about us
so you know i don't
i don't know what's going on it's almost
like we
it's almost like there's a 78 year old
man in office i'm not sure but he's
this guy according to the reports anyway
he's
he's just
farting all over europe
it's a real problem here
especially with you know with with
pollution being the pro being being as
bad as it is
he's he has crop dusted all of europe
what what's what's happening
well again i know what's happening he's
an old man
and there's no way like there's no
there's no i'm just trying to imagine
first of all i need to know more about
this okay
because even in the daily mail report i
read the whole report with great
interest
and then it kind of moves on and it
talks about the climate change summit
doesn't give us any more information i
need to know more
because joe biden is standing there
allegedly and he lets out this massive
fart
that goes on for minutes apparently does
is there a pause in the conversation
or does he blow through it and keep
talking pretending that it's not
happening
is there any acknowledgement of the fart
after the fact
it sounds like he does this a lot
hopefully he's he's kind of got
accustomed he knows what what tactics to
use to distract from what's just
happened i don't know
a lot more information that we need
but this this just makes us proud as
americans
doesn't it
[Music]
you know one one weekend he uh poops his
pants in front of the pope allegedly the
very next weekend
he's farting in front of the duchess of
cornwall of all people
makes me very proud to be an american
all right now time for the comment
section
[Music]
jim says i'd like matt to acknowledge
that he occupied stolen land in loudoun
county in that ladies basement that's
that land was not stolen that was that
was given to me fair and square
so there would be no land
acknowledgement for from me in reference
to loudoun county ethan says matt is
definitely the type to text back k and
not think anything of it um i would
never do that i would spell it out well
i would okay you know the letter o and
then k i don't i don't uh because i
i don't i don't speak that way okay i
text the way that i speak
so i'm not gonna say to someone okay
i'll say this whole thing but i'll
certainly we'll have no problem with
that i'll just text back oh that's what
i like about text messages i'll do the
same thing with emails too
all the time i'll respond to an email
yeah because if the email's a question
hey know matt i hope you're doing well i
hope this and that and how your kids do
it and by the way here's my question my
answer back will be uh yeah
or no
end of end of email send
because that's the whole advantage of
email and texting is that i don't need
to do any of that small talk
um
mark says matt i was thinking you should
get a second dog so yours has a buddy to
play with no that's that's
that's the last thing that we need you
know we're actually having a problem
with the with the dog
at least it's a problem for me i'm gonna
throw this out there if there's any dog
whispers this is a serious thing if
there's any dog whisperers in the
audience maybe you can give me your your
insight so the issue is i think i i
mentioned this like a month ago that we
you know we got the dog we adopted the
dog and then we had the dog for three
days and i went away for a week
um
and i came back
and every time i walk in the room the
dog would bark at me because it's like
he bonded with his pack and i'm and i
wasn't in the pack
and now where it's a month later has not
changed
so my wife started saying well maybe you
need to feed the dog and give him treats
and you know so you're constantly
groveling and sucking up to this mangy
beast in the house and i said you know
what i'm i'm so tired of getting barked
at i will do that so i feed the dog i
give him treats
come here little boy here's you here's
your treat
and uh maybe i'm being sarcastic about
it and that's probably maybe he's
picking up on that i don't know
but it hasn't changed it's actually
gotten worse every time i walk into a
room now he barks
it's like he has not i'm i have not
earned my place in the pack in my own
house
um
so if anyone has any in all seriousness
if anyone because it's ruining my life
so if you have any suggestions on what
to do about that let me know tracy says
i'm sitting here dumbfounded as to how
people could just know someone for three
hours and do that hookups are an insane
practice referring back to the dave
portnoy thing um
yeah hook-up culture but you know
something tracy
the fact that you would not
want to be sexually active with someone
who you just met
and have known for three hours
that now puts you that's that's its own
sexuality i think that's what they call
demisexuality now you're a demisexual
did you know that
if you prefer
to have a you know some kind of
emotional
involvement with someone at least to
know something about them
if that's even bear let alone you want
to be married first
now we call now that is uh you've got
your own letter in the lgbt alphabet
you're a demisexual whether you want it
or not you know
that that has become that used to be
well you're a normal healthy person
but now that's just one variation that's
one sexual variation among millions
and they're all equal
um
jack says matt after seeing your most
recent anniversary anniversary slash
vacation photos has it occurred to you
that the only report necessary to defeat
all of your internet adversaries is have
you seen my wife i win
um
yeah i do i you know i do have a very
attractive wife which i do think
but i try not to use that in arguments
because it would be weird to do but i do
think that sometimes
um
and uh let's see yo yo yo says i feel
your pain matt i bought my girlfriend a
nice bottle of white wine and she poured
seven up into it
i was literally speechless poured seven
up in the is that eve is that a thing
that people do
that to me seems like a breakup offense
you know my wife were married
the fact that she wasted my very nice
burden but putting in t that's a that's
the kind of thing you work through we're
going to counseling for it right now
um but seven up in wine to me especially
it's it's early on that's kind of like a
red flag i already you know i've i've
been with my wife for 10 years i know
this was a momentary lapse of judgment
normally she has a great amount of
respect for whiskey she would never
normally do that so
i have all of that background
but if you're just dating someone and
they're pouring seven up in their white
wine
i hate to say but i think that's
i think you got to cut that rope i i
hate to say as you heard last week the
daily wire made one of the biggest
announcements it will ever make that
it's filing a lawsuit against the
federal government this is an
unprecedented move for the daily wire
but staring down the face of an
increasingly authoritarian president
leaves no other options our senile
leader has ordered that large employers
must require their employees to get
vaccinated against covet or submit to
regular testing the daily wires lawsuit
was filed by the dillon law group and
alliance defending freedom they do a lot
of great work and they're helping us
with this in the u.s court of appeals
for the sixth circuit the lawsuit
alleges that the bible administration
lacks constitutional and statutory
authority to issue the employer mandate
which would seem they obviously do
because look this mandate is absolutely
unconstitutional and we're not standing
for it here at the daily wire but we
need your help if you want to stand up
against this tyranny alongside us then
become a daily wire member today go to
dailywire.com subscribe enter code do
not comply at checkout and you'll
receive 25 off your membership you'll
also be helping us fight this
unconstitutional mandate also as always
we have more exciting news here at the
daily wire we're launching daily wire
now which means that you'll be able to
stream all of your favorite daily wire
shows on vizio smartcast you can tune in
to watch candace discuss current events
with guests ranging from donald trump to
dana white or catch one of your favorite
hosts uh you know like for example me or
or me
uh there's always something interesting
to stream watch daily wire now
exclusively on vizio watch free plus
streaming app on channel 162 to access
the content you love 24 hours a day
seven days a week only on vizio
smartcast now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel equality and
this has been a long time coming
equality has been asking for it and now
the moment has arrived of course every
day there's some new lunacy concocted in
the name of equality you could just
google the word equality on any given
day and you'll be guaranteed to find a
headline like this one here's just the
most recent example
from the new york post it says uk
primary schools ask boys to wear skirts
to promote equality
reading on it says a grade school in
scotland asked male and female students
and teachers to wear skirts to class to
promote equality we want our school to
be inclusive and promote equality an
email from castlev primary in edinburgh
said to parents the daily mail reported
on wednesday boys as young as three
years old were asked to participate
by wearing a skirt
uh it says we're keen to spread the
message that clothes don't have a gender
and that we should all be free to
express ourselves as we choose teachers
wrote a message to parents according to
the outlet
now equality here is just the cover
story as is so often the case an adult
who asks a little boy to put on a skirt
has no doubt other intentions and
motivations
he's probably a pedophile is what i'm
trying to say in case i wasn't being
clear enough with the insinuation
but this is still one more instance of
the sort of madness that the west's
obsession with equality has wrought it
seems to be infecting schools especially
some school systems have done away with
grading systems because of equality
they've abolished gifted and talented
programs in the name of equality
equality has put an end to most of the
games we used to play in recess and gym
class
of course equality is what has
opened the girls bathroom to boys
equality has wreaked havoc in education
and there's a reason why the education
system in particular is concerned with
equality we'll get to that in a minute
but this extends far beyond education
everywhere our society is being
restructured around the concept of
equality
and along with its dysgenic offspring
equity tolerance inclusion all of them
all kind of related currently the
equality act is working its way through
congress a piece of legislation which
seeks to legally abolish once and for
all the biological differences between
sexes
but those differences cannot be
abolished
so instead we will simply be forbidden
from noticing or acknowledging or in any
way acting upon or in response to those
differences
so overall it's clear that we are an
equality obsessed culture
before we talk about why equality
obsession is bad
it should be and i think it would be
illuminating and useful to discuss why
the obsession exists in the first place
where did it come from you know why why
are this society's past you go you go
through human history
um you didn't have this
um
but why why for us why are we so
obsessed with equality that's that's a
large question not one that i can answer
completely during this segment but here
are two major factors
first we are a self-obsessed
narcissistic culture
and equality ironically is a major
concern of self-obsessed narcissistic
people because they wield equality as a
negative force
they're constantly worried that other
people are advancing beyond them
succeeding more than them getting more
out of life
and so they call for equality as a means
to chop everybody back down to their
level you'll notice that so often the
person calling for equality is not
calling for others to be raised up to
his level but for everyone to be lowered
down to his level
equality is kind of a weed whack or
cutting the blades of grass that grow
higher than the rest
and it's often the lower blades pointing
to the higher ones and saying get him
cut him down to size it's not fair that
he's growing faster and higher than me
we know that leftism is the religion of
self-worship it's an ideology of
narcissism and so it's no surprise that
a society dominated by leftism would
also be preoccupied with equality with
especially negative equality of this
kind
the second factor can be found on the
other end of the spectrum
it kind of approaches from the opposite
direction while equality is very often a
tool used by narcissistic losers to
prevent others from succeeding it can
also be born from confused and misplaced
empathy
so like i said this is kind of the
opposite thing here
this is where much of the equality in
the school system originates not the
scottish kids wearing skirts as i said
that's just pervert teachers using
equality as a cover but the erasing of
grades the abolition of playground games
the abolition of gifted and talented
programs and so on that is all at least
partly
misdirected empathy
and you find it in the school system so
prominently because the school system is
run by women
okay this is the part that media matters
is going to love so make sure you click
this part guys
equality is in many ways a feminine
virtue
it's a woman's virtue it's something
women tend to care about much more than
much more than men women are more
worried about you know making sure that
things are fair
that things are equal
that nobody feels bad about themselves
and nobody gets hurt emotionally or
physically
that's something that women tend to be
concerned about
um much more than men men are more
competitive they're more
results-oriented they're much more
likely to take a you know may the best
man win approach
but as men are driven more and more out
of education this voice
the voice that says to the crying child
who got his nose bloody during dodgeball
hey rub some dirt on it you'll be fine
now get back out there and try to win
the next round
that voice has been almost entirely
silenced
now a kid gets his nose bloodied playing
dodgeball and so we say no more
dodgeball for anybody it's over
now we have a system where there's
almost no competition no harshness at
all no toughness no winners or losers
kids are coddled they're mothered
they're pampered
and they're not remotely prepared for
the realities of life it's not just in
the education system as men are
minimized more and more replaced driven
out of positions of leadership and so on
all that means is that our society will
be increasingly revolving around
feminine concerns like equality
tolerance inclusion you find this in
parenting as well
you know you need the balance in
parenting you have the the mother who
typically is again going to be very
concerned about about making sure things
are fair uh it's going to be the much
more empathetic voice and you need that
that's very important
but you also need the masculine fatherly
voice
that embraces competition that embraces
risk-taking
you know that the kid scrapes their knee
and he's not going to
go run over immediately he's going to
say no you can't get back
you don't need to cry about that you'll
be fine get back out there
children need both
but you know increasingly as as men
as we have fatherless homes and and
families where there's no where there's
no
masculine presence
kids don't have that balance
so why is it a problem you know what's
wrong with equality
well the problem with equality is that
it's a fiction it's a mythology there is
no equality in the world the only place
where equality is supposed to exist is
in the legal system okay we're supposed
to all be equal under the law meaning
that nobody is granted special treatment
or favors but even there it's still
really a fiction
we do not have a legal system that
treats everybody equally and we never
have and we probably never will
it is at best a theoretically attainable
ideal in the legal system
we're probably never going to get there
but we should try i agree with that
outside of that realm
equality neither exists
nor is it attainable nor desirable
because everyone is different everything
is different
you will not find two apples in a barrel
that are the same or two grains of sand
on a beach
much less two people
take two people at random and compare
them and one will be uglier fatter
dumber less virtuous less creative less
generous etc hopefully all of those
lesser qualities will not be found in
the same person but you never know we're
all a mixed bag and for some of us the
mixture is better than others
this is all undeniable
the advocates for an equal society a
society where sameness is opposed upon
us from the top from people who are
themselves above us unequal by the way
these advocates know that we're not
really equal yet they argue that we
should live as though we are
our systems should be built upon the
false assumption of equality
equality is a story that they tell and
they insist that we live as though the
story is true even though we know it
isn't
in the most extreme kind of example you
know you've got like a man who
identifies as a woman and harasses and
harangues lesbians who don't want to
sleep with him
he'll say that he's equal to the same as
biological women and so they ought to be
attracted to him the same way that
they're attracted to other women
but they're not
because equality is a story it's a stage
play and the equality advocate demands
that everybody play their part go along
with the script even if it's all
fictional
so that's my issue with equality when
you boil it down it's a lie
we're not equal
we weren't really created equal either
with all due respect to thomas jefferson
we're equal in a very abstract and
spiritual sense in the sense that we all
have dignity and worth as human beings
sure but outside of that
we were created very unequal very
different with vastly different
qualities characteristic traits and
abilities
and thank god for that
imagine how boring and dismal and
pointless life would be if everyone you
encountered was merely a carbon copy of
yourself
imagine if there was no one better than
you on earth
no one to look up to or admire no role
models
that's the leftist utopian vision
but the vision is nightmare
and it's not real
and never can be
and we should stop pretending that it is
that's why equality today is canceled
a segment that i'm sure will
garner rave reviews and everybody will
agree with me
um and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinckle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
the united states navy names a ship
after an infamous pederast a tabloid
journalist tries to me to dave portwhite
barstool sports and an appeals judge
puts a stop to joe biden's vaccine
mandate
for now check it out on the michael
knowles show